you
[Music]
okay so they come everyone thank you so
much for coming it's my pleasure to
introduce Jennifer Robinson who actually
interned a few years ago at Microsoft
Research and she's a doctoral candidate
at North Carolina State University
Microsoft Research Fellow NSF arrow and
a national G & consortium fellow and
today she is going to talk to us about
designing infrastructure for her
programming communities
so thanks thanks for the in short time
so again I pretty much never in this
room but I'm Danae for Robinson mom and
I wouldn't talk to you all about the
Yahoo Answers for program is essentially
so I'm talking about how we can bridge
understand the barriers so Khomeini's
like stack overflow as a framework now
where have you target as few people who
are having troubles contributing and how
we can use those as a way to build
interventions this was a lot of waiting
as well but just get started I want to
make sure your wheels are turning in the
right direction so you can close your
eyes but since I could take a beat and I
want you to imagine what a soft manner
looks like I would say Andy close your
eyes don't just look at me okay that's
that's it let's be honest you're
probably thinking of someone who looks
like this hey but I want to challenge
you to shift your thinking a bit to
think of the diverse group of people
learning to code and thus entering the
technical workforce so it's tools like
Coursera ger developed for these coding
boot camps a lot of people are learning
to code there's a big emphasis and
getting everyone to code but what about
the resources to keep them there so
there's a few people learning to code
but I want to be able to understand how
we can target the few experiences of
people diverse people learning and how
we can believe understand we can
increase that to help the many so
targeting the few help that many that's
gonna be the theme practice work
essentially
and a lot of people do need hope I'm
Mitchell about who learning to code so
by show of hands you can bring some hi
how many of you have heard of stock
overflow okay keep your hand raised if
you ever posted there okay yeah it's
okay that's reasonable
so for those of you who may not be
familiar I think everyone raised their
hands you you posted a yeah well a
people who don't lose not you who don't
write so those who are familiar with
that goal flow this is an example of the
thread they were there about as of mid
February there is about 17 million
questions this is one of the examples of
what it looks like and this is one of
the 26 million answers so just just give
you an example of what it looks like you
see who's posting their their rankings
their points as well as who's asked just
a new schedule idea of what it looks
like but you can guess what these
millions of post that a lot of people do
contribute but there's a part of you who
don't you look around the room so I'll
have the handset and to really drop that
home I'm going to introduce the
motivating example of a show the
programmer so let's get an author she's
a programmer oh so she's at Microsoft
machine counts as a program the air so
say a copilot air she copies it into
being a not Google this time so tailored
my top so I was being and it's that go
full on the top response to that popped
up from there she finds ants if it kind
of matches what she has them or a
question that matches hers goes on to
the answer but doesn't quite work for
what she's doing right now so because it
doesn't she finally muscles up enough
courage to post her own question but
while she's posting she types the body
in the title of the question something
stops Asha you wanted to be able to
figure out what that is
so a couple of things could be happening
one it could be the ah she doesn't see
other people who look like her I
mentioned about you can see who edited
and asked the question here you don't
really have to include an image of what
you look like but she doesn't see one
based on names they make it look like
her
also there's maybe unfamiliar norms and
expectations of how to contribute to the
community so here's an example of a
question that was markets protected
versus to prevent thanks and me too and
spam from new users so it's very
explicit in the concept that can be
discouraging you see how that can be
discouraging third Asha may think her
questions at duplicates so when Osaka
for when you type in the title of your
question you will start to see other
similar questions I have a clicker above
the pointer yeah questions pop up it may
feel like if you're adding clutter to
the community that you find so valuable
for it that has such high utility so so
these are those examples of what may be
plaguing Asha and other developers even
in this room if experiences but in order
to get a bigger understanding of this I
want to ground it and who's using Stack
Overflow period so Stack Overflow has
about 50 million visits per month and
this is according to the developer
server they produced every year out of
that amount but ten million people have
accounts so it's a small percentage of
people who are actually engaged or start
to get engaged and then do not post also
this less than to give an idea of the
demographics in the community there's
about less than 7% of women consuming an
open-source and this includes that
little flow github and this is from a
couple of surveys over time but this is
really low comparison the number of
women who are developers in industry the
software engineers in the classroom the
upcoming people in computer science
courses
another number I'm just throwing numbers
at you right now but a third of the
users have less than five years
experience there's a lot of people
learning to code I mentioned so this is
the from the device echo flow developer
server as well where you see the worst
percentage of people are learning in
this slide and this is really again I'm
just throwing a lot of numbers at you
here to drive home a point of who's
engaging on the platform
there's also this economic opportunity
that some people may be missing out on
so on Stack Overflow you can get paid
between or based on fifty to hundred
dollars an hour based on having more
than 5,000 to 20,000 points or even
contributing to open source projects
online so there's an opportunity here so
try and drive on the point that a lot of
people don't contribute oh the the
financial gain up opportunity to have a
career economic opportunity to have a
career in tech oh no no no so people
excuse me oh no no cycles this is a good
question
no suck this is people who are having so
job postings so this is career postings
that were had requirements or some of
the application materials requested if
you had these were highlights to them if
you had between five and twenty thousand
points if you contribute to other open
source projects so these were these were
having
yeah
so essentially so you consider it opens
community service in a way right so
you're contributing it developers so
people put it on their resume your
question good question so I'm really
trying to open look at the problem here
which is programmers especially
underrepresented users and clean offices
as well have an issue in contributing to
open source communities I'm sorry I only
program in communities and when I say
all my programming communities I'll be
physically talking about that overflow
and kind of get help today for my vision
but there's others as well there's a
gitlab there's this job of a cold ranch
there's there's a lot here and just to
get in the range it was yeah so those
are so the in the who's Anna filipova
who was in Jesse slotnick who's at
github they did an open source survey so
it's actually open source of rhetoric
and they submitted to survey they had
about less than seven percent women and
non-binary individuals included who was
bonded that survey yeah and of course
would get him okay good question good
question
Jenna filipova who's a researcher she I
think she was at github for a year now
she started working on that before she
got there right before she got there
doing her postdoc and then the numbers I
report is well for the stackoverflow
developer survey last year they had 7.6
percent the year before they've like
five point eight percent of women yes so
I know covers topics beyond programming
right I mean there's finance pop culture
and all that kind of stuff
have you looked at the diversity figures
for non software topics to see if it's
any better in any other so that's a good
question so this package so there under
the stack exchange umbrella and I'll
show a picture of over there's over one
hundred and seventy two communities
under the stock exchange brother so
there's math and travel so there's
numbers that served on the math last
exchange there were high percentages of
women so more like 20% but that was a
separate studies that someone did
so yeah but you can consider it well I'm
like driving too deep into the woods I
might I might dig diving too deep into
the weeds I'll come back to that later
good question good question okay so what
makes this problem really hard is being
able to understand this community
without stereotyping artists izing them
so we want to be able to accommodate or
not a comedy but understand the
experience so to do that I'm doing a
work and intersection of software
engineering social computing as well
using mixed methods so again trying to
understand the experience so some things
can't just be quantified the number it's
great to have the statistics to
understand what's happening at scale for
missing out on the sentiment or the
experience my future work because I've
been to add any signals I'll talk a
little bit more that at the end so first
I'm going to talk about how we are
identifying barriers as a framework I
mentioned earlier and using those
barriers as this framework for
interventions to build increase
participation to the mentorship so
project one so to do this I mentioned I
emphasize a little bit about the group
that's not participating so we're
starting there so the first research
question is what barriers to women on
stackoverflow faced and how these
barriers for our research question two
is how these barriers barrier by gender
there's also a third question here which
you can't really see but I won't cover
it much back I talk more about it which
is how these barriers manifest across
experiences so whether or not you have
an account full-time student versus
full-time developer so
I'll be doing awkward pauses to wait for
questions so okay so again I'm doing
this we started with this mixed methods
approach so our q1 will really start
with these semi-structured interviews
and our cue to kind of emphasizes this
globally distributed survey with men and
women so it was a binary version so
first part for the experiment with
conducting semi-trucks interviews with
women we've recruited about when you've
we had 25 for respondents in 22 actually
joined the interviews and one of which
was identified as a top-ranked user of
all time and so there is important to
understand his personal experience
because of this first twenty one they
were identifying what's stopping them
was inhibiting their participation
welcome but with the top one we could
figure out how these may not be barriers
for this person and we can encourage
others the 21 participants to have this
experience so to get a standing of what
that looks like we asked about scenarios
we asked them about scenarios for why
they will participate even propose other
instances that they may not have been
familiar with so again the demographic
here were the students professionals
lurkers which are half the room
essentially people who look but don't
contribute as well as active users okay
so the interview analysis I'm myself and
to my collaborators transcribed the 22
transcripts and identify statements that
said things like I would post but I was
going to post but something stopped me
to move back to ashes experience from
there we identified 327 various
statements so this was justice Smith and
Vincents with him last year so this is
actually just tacking the same statement
just identified that we identified that
this was both a barrier I identify the
heat there was a barian heated as well
I'll be no need to be the actual code I
kind of emphasize that our next slide
from the 300
but yeah good question good question
so from there we identify 14 barrier
statements they exist across three
categories I won't be talking about all
14 but one of all explain the categories
so one of them is this muddy Lance
perspective this misconception of how
people should be using the community
versus how they're using it um
there's lack of impersonal interactions
so people not being able to identify the
human asking the question the humanity
in it and the third was these are meant
roadblocks so thinking about ahsha's
experience where everyone had every
intention to post but was inhibited by
some other force I'll talk about three
so the first one to talk about with
qualifications which is similar to that
quote right there so again these were
quotes from women
so one participant going on to say I
don't feel like my expertise is enough
for me to actually post an answer that
would be of any help to anyone else so
this sounds a lot like something we've
seen in offline spaces as well imposter
syndrome right so it's really cool to be
able to identify these experiences that
exists these off my spaces and I have
empirical evidence for how they exist
here so another one another participant
went on to say just for onboarding hoops
I feel like everyone else already knows
what it is supposed to is and I want to
say away from the extra work to figure
out how to use it just just figure out
what that etiquette is a little social
unspoken kinds of dialogue this is going
back to the idea of those unfamiliar
norms engaging a new space yes
how many years experience so this is
something they often using free for a
while for more than a year and they're
developed so there will be asked that on
the paper is a development experience so
that's different because some of them
were students right versus industry so
when we asked him about their
experiences we accidentally referred to
them glass concrete explain so
stackoverflow so likely the day before
or early earlier that day during the
interview yeah I mean think about how
often we go to second floor then right
good question good question okay so that
there when I cover with the sphere of
negative feedback so this participant
goes on to say it's hard enough to ask
for help but to ask for help and get
rude help it's kind of like never mind
right this disengagement so I kind of
Brandon this is conflict avoidance but
it's really just I really don't like
using that term I should've changed it
which is really just the unlike we could
see engage in this violent behavior and
toxic behavior I guess
good question with three about five of
them were conducted on skype so I don't
know what countries they were in so but
but but people but the other part we're
conducting physically in Raleigh yes a
good question I'm good yes to this
question I don't really have a good feel
looked at it from that perspective but
you know how much rude behavior is there
separate right so two as a fundamental
challenge for the whole approach is it
have these bad behaviors and they will
delete the offensive comments as well so
the moderators are fairly active they're
actually doing elections for moderators
right now I'm a psych overflow but I
would say that Retta has a different
moderation content strategy the sec
overflow does the second floor has been
around longer so the tone that's allowed
on the platform but that's normalized
that has already been normalized is
there vs. and there's a whole different
other part of that too because reddit
has been working with a lot of academic
researchers as well I'm so Susan
banished she was at Harvard who was
doing a lot with Nathan matthias on this
civility increase in civility in these
platforms and how you can encourage
positive or voluntary compliance so but
Sacco flow that that's gonna happen for
a while I'm psycho flows just me I guess
right now
to respond to a question on Stack
Overflow what information did they get
about the yes so when you are going to
respond so you're answering a question
right so you can see the what time it
was asked who that person is right by
the profile image you can clear their
username given him the display the
points the members badges they have the
the tags of the question you can click
on the name so I'm really going
definitely but you can click on the name
be able to see what country they're from
what other questions they've experiences
they've asked and what the badges they
have as well and now you can start to
see developer profile as well so it's an
explicit CV that Stack Overflow has so
javis their main bread-and-butter so
they really try to encourage people to
be to pull their full information on
there and fully disclose more no you
have access to a lot if you're willing
to go into the week right if you're if
you're at that type of answer and you
want to know more about who you're
responding to and there's been
experiences when people have said you
know um I seen that you access like this
before or somewhere else or and refer to
a previous experience good question
Oh so I'll lightly cover q2 and then
over his keyboard we'll see how long it
goes but for our q2 we want to
understand how these barriers vary by
gender so after myself and my colleagues
analyze transcripts we determined 214
barriers we submitted a survey in this
distributor survey this survey had 14
quest or 15 questions really 14 of them
with the 14 barriers asking them how
likely is this to be a barrier for you
and that's a Likert scale from 1 to 5
he's really hard to see there and then
we asked another question which was you
know are there any barriers that we
missed we want to be able to understand
there was a contribution that we were
just didn't have here from that we
received responses from over 1400
developers and we identified 5 of those
barriers that were significantly
hindering women typically so of the 15
barriers or of the 14 barriers or the
responses that they gave all of them fit
into the existing 14 yes how often is
this a barrier for you so we asked about
their person experience good good point
we went some because as concrete as
possible so again talk about your own
experience so good question
what was the target yeah super question
so we were recruited through our kind of
our snowball sampling so the way we
distribute the survey we're in in
probably every Research Triangle Park so
we have a slew of developers from all
over we have IBM's
like the works and my collaborators were
kind of Co dispersed it was Philip well
at the time he was in New York and then
he came down see here at one point and
then he went down to UC San Diego I say
here means that Microsoft were a bit
yeah okay cool yeah so you'll notice
here so we had about 130 for women and
over 1300 men identify um so you notice
here that's the alpha level that's point
zero zero one two that's because the
double all the comparisons we did across
the user status and the employment
status as well so that we done the
question to reduce the health level what
I want to show you here is that these
are the five barriers we identified to
be significant so here's the
qualifications when I mentioned earlier
so that impostor syndrome and so it's
interesting to see again that that is
when that's highlighted a lot for
underrepresented groups for engaging in
platforms erasing the same thing here so
offline communities as well as online I
also watched this fear of negative
feedback down low here below um no it
was maxim that they came by again just
when to demonstrate these barriers exist
across the spectrum yes yes yes it's the
same as left the right strongly agree to
strongly disagree yes yes songi disagree
okay Shawn we agree yes yep so should be
consistent with that one
oh these papers you'll notice that at
the bottom there's titles of stuff this
is probably the FSC in 2016 and the
other ones will say the conference
impressed met before
yeah so so you ever interpreted as well
zero to three being low four to six
being medium 69 being high so we're
seeing a medium effect size so of how
often or how can this expanse
generalizability to other populations
that make sense so medium generalize
really is both good question
okay so again as well you really want to
drive home the point that these berries
exist across the spectrum
so what I'll show you next is a
diverging stacked bar chart where the
screen to orange spectrum identifies
women this blue to mustard identifies
men and you'll notice again that these
stars are or ones that were significant
bears that were significant yes yes no
no we it was so when we when we
accidentally interviewed them we did not
request their profiles because many of
them had accounts but they didn't log
into them before so there's another
person who did a survey Roger swag I
don't worry is that now but sixty
percent of people have a make an account
you only have one point which mean you
get one point for just logging your name
so it's yeah I mean the number of people
who have I mean basically it's like
nobody contributes yeah so I mean I
wonder I'm not going to understand that
there's there's clearly a difference as
you've shown in terms of the perception
of the barriers but it seems like
nobody's contributing yeah so it's funny
you mentioned that so a long time ago my
adviser a Chris Brown in fact this value
he did like this lower scale study when
he found out about 5% of the users were
answering 60% of the questions so it's a
very small elite group of who started
off with Jeff at what's friendship at
was the founder
he's a start off with his buddy six
answer questions and that don't just
persisted for a while
yeah so again that's when to show this
don't we just don't read this do not
read it the point is it's a demonstrate
again there's various things across the
spectrum for everyone and I do want to
acknowledge that I mentioned ones that
were significant by box the other three
for a reason so though these were
important to acknowledge that these were
significantly hindering women again the
goal was to target the few help the many
so these ones that my box were actually
really helpful for expanding to industry
and my collaborators with Stack Overflow
for what they were interested in and
doing what they had the resources to
build on yes
this is a good question and I think this
is a this is a common to be actually
with so what I'm hearing real so it's
maybe there's a value and having know
only a few people post and I would say
that they're psycho flows we this half
wiki half forum in a way where the forum
is that transaction of being able to ask
a question and get that feedback
instantly but the wiki part of it
preserving it right having that archive
of the limited people engaged well
that's what they accepted answers are
for right
even though those accepted answers are
really only for the person who ants ask
the question so I think there's I think
there's two ways I could go yeah sorry I
was thinking yeah
yeah so um other than gender or
referring to you see status yeah so for
as far as those demographics as far as
like cultural demographics know we could
be a name request that's for the
participants but since the time I came a
couple times I just showed us five real
quick which is how we split it across
yeah so this is the conductivity versus
experience so and these were the how the
barriers resonated across these groups
so that's what we did
so were the blocking this where the
experience full-time developed so you
can interpret on developers rate this is
worse than if these were than with ever
since picking for them the time
constraint in the qualifications the
post time castrates can think about if
your industry developer you're not
getting paid to contributors that go
flow right you're getting paid it's a
time for saying you don't post go you
don't have time to post that go the flow
right so that's so that's consistent you
know that's that looks logical right and
this house accounts versus not having
accounts over enters the features well
you should maybe you're not aware of
features because you haven't been able
to engage i'm fully with their with the
community
that's all we did bouncer for this set
at least you know if you have a small
number of people answering questions and
there's an economic value to getting
points then isn't there an economic
value for them to prevent other people
from answering questions or attorney to
discourage other people your question
because in the end you know if somebody
else answers them they don't and then
they lose money because they don't have
the same star rating or whatever right
so this is I seems like it it's a
structural problem with the relationship
between making money and being a
question/answer at some level and if
that's the case then what you have is
you have an entrenched minority you know
who you know historically have been
Muslim and I think you know defending
essentially in some kind of economic
terms potentially they're no they're not
you do get badges for answering some I
think that's a different mindset that's
like the scarcity mindset versus versus
this I don't want to think I don't know
with opposite term of what I'm trying to
say is but going back to what Andy and I
are saying there's opportunities for
everyone suppose then you still have the
ability to upload and get more points
that way because not just the person
asking the question can upload and
accept you can get points from from
anyone right and part of the value of
cycles will go much to the half wiki
half forum is be able to have the this
core role what I call it as coral
explanations as in this multitude of
voices contributing to this one answer
right this is together it's a collective
or divide by the actuality of whether or
not many more people contribute versus
maybe the perception if you're one of
the people who's you know you can sort
of justify putting something like for
example I can do you can justify putting
somebody down if they don't if they're
not
authoritative which it sounds like
that's the culture right if somebody
doesn't have a good answer they get you
know they get negative feedback
essentially right yeah yeah I reckon ah
makes it yeah so I have this kind of
economic perspective on behavior and it
does seem like in this case there might
be a relationship people have frameworks
actually is the way to respond to your
users so so fundamentally there's also a
very popular framework for people could
probably compete a lot it's not scarce
there's probably so many things people
want to know about it and as new as new
languages pop up Brian as new tools pop
up there's that which there's a new
opportunity suppose there's a new
culture essentially going around how we
talk about us particular topic even even
a lot of the visual studio extensions
they're linked to Stack Overflow
questions they say oh let's check out
this on Stack Overflow if you're
building an extension and that's the you
can search for this tag and it's linked
from the Microsoft Visual Studio website
it engage yeah yeah yeah so good good
questions with that yes it's like
there's an opportunity here too
where you could potentially discover
some let's say linguistic features that
go along with posts that make people
feel stranger discomfort or intimidating
sighs whatever and modified the search
from search ranking system to down to
those results and yes even building on
yes and of the building when you're even
typing the title of your question if you
know this person to you by that point
you have an account right if you can
tell the point value of the values and
the badges of the person has in other
languages they contributed to maybe if
they're a new user list that's another
opportunity to to change the ranking
algorithm of what you're showing or
maybe not show anything at all so listen
get that first experience but there's
the downside of that too of just
throwing them into the fire right so
yeah did you have a hand okay all right
um I'm already at 30 minutes okay real
quick is it quick okay big all this
conversation is great so there's a point
here is that yes there's I'm welcoming
atmosphere on Stack Overflow and
participants really acknowledge that
this boys club idle chatter can be
discouraging but two participants have
every intention to post they want to
post they want to engage in some way but
are unclear on the opportunities on how
to do that okay I'm just gonna just the
justice briefly then go to the next one
so the impact of some of these barriers
is that after doing that work for FSC
Jeff Atwood who again is the founder of
Stack Overflow really highlighted the
work and even trying to be intentional
try to propose new tools of ways of
engaging in writing newcomers I haven't
said when in action I have an accent
about that but was helpful for that
process is be posting the blog so that's
been able to help facilitate some of
these collaborations with industry for
myself
but they also allow users so people who
are not in participants in my studies to
engage with with each other and so this
participant goes on or this user goes on
to talk about you know how their
identify as a woman how about hip if I
help them fire is real of people always
constantly sucking about or
trying to get the quickness from the
community and kind of reducing the value
and then but the point was that the
blog's are helpful Jeff Atwood liked it
and that facilitated a collaboration was
that coverflow wishes the mentorship
program so I briefly talked about this
real quick which is the the novice
experience is essentially what I
highlighted earlier there it receives a
lot of them have low boats again
somebody commenting on the actual blog
which goes on to say you know more of
them know not
my post gets downloaded because I didn't
follow some arcane etiquette and then
here another but participants are
interested in contributing so it is
particularly wanted to say or those
comments are on a blog goes on to say
you know is there some trick to making
this work so that's what we're taught to
figure out is there a trick how do we
get novices to hacks well with these
questions to do this we're understanding
Socktober flexus community of practice
so i canta highlighted earlier where
each thread is a way to determine how
we're going to talk about a topic
experts are coming experts in offices of
like are coming to a thread to
understand something it could be
something new but also evaluating how
we've gone the dialogue had the
sentiment or was allowed when we talked
about this topic so you can kind of
compare this to Wikipedia right where
the people are learning from mutual
engagement again novices and experts
learning into the same space so trying
to put the different lens on
question-answer communities and to do
that we're trying to figure out how we
can increase mutual engagement through
this legitimate peripheral participation
and to do that we did this with this
Stack Overflow exploratory study so you
probably know something more your face
here yeah so this is a so in order to do
that we had a closed private space we
had novices and mentors engage this is
flack but we were really trying to pilot
it simulate what this will look like
before doing this on platform but there
were a couple things that went wrong
here I'm trying to figure out how we
were gonna do this engagement one there
was this context switching between
platforms so we were trying to recreate
this activity of or encourage novices
expert of questions but here you see
there was a copy post a copy pasted from
sac overflow so this this constant
context switching this high cognitive
load switching between platforms like
can encourage disengagement likewise
this eighth circuit is communication you
notice here that the novice went on to
ask a question it's 157 the mentor here
we're on 7 or 9 p.m. that 6 hours later
you know the novice didn't need hope
there's not Titus it's somebody else say
then that was he need help then nothing
he hopes examples later they needed help
then Hey
so that was important that's what we
learned also the dialogue that we were
trying correct here or trying to create
didn't refine questions it really just
added but add a little bit of noise so
long story short we learned a lot from
the experience for this private study of
what we want this peripheral
participation to look like so we kind of
with a couple of design principles for
that we wanted to make sure we allowed
will be found helpful was that allowing
mistakes to happen in a private space
again this was a private slack channel
it was very helpful for novices and
mentors alike also the ability to
provide formative so this iterative
timely feedback so again when obviously
need to help not six hours later that's
the value somewhere now we've even
further realized the value of psycho
flows that you can get answers in the
short amount of time and how that's very
important for analysis but also again we
wanted to create this legitimate
peripheral participation a new pathway
to participation so we wanted to teach
the novices ask better questions not ask
to them for them or not ask them for
them so teaching them to finish not
fishing for them so that was something
learned it was really important
yes well we wanted to see how if it
would help if that added value to the
experience cuz right now sucker flow
when you post the answer or even if
you're a new user it goes to the public
the books there and you're sometimes
people call it public shaming speed with
the shame master and Game of Thrones
right where everyone can publicly see
you're getting downloaded people can
publicly see your your comments they're
like this isn't helpful this is adding
value to the site this is this belongs
somewhere else right so but those are
the experiences translating from our
barriers that are discouraging to users
so so for example a barrier was this
intimidating community sighs how do we
make the community feel smaller that's
less intimidating how we get to me
smaller and how does that how does that
encourage participation so really trying
to read and again the barriers as a
framework so how we can build
interventions
/ you could direct people to a chat yeah
it was not a setting of slightly yeah it
was just the platform I use for that yes
exactly that's exactly right so we
trying to see if that was valuable and
that's what we did here for this next
part so we implemented this feature
I was collaborative editing feature it's
really hard to see but this is a
collaborative question draft here we got
the body of the question or the title
the question of the tags the body for
the coasts snippet as well and we put
this in a private channel so we went
weeds from the slack we understood that
that was actually valuable to have but
in order to do that on platform that
require a lot abhayam Seco it her so we
need to test that out before so good
question
so we have this help we call this as
private help forum and we had about four
of them but in this help room you can
get feedback from a mentor privately in
the private space and not on the public
forum on your question so feedback on
how to improve your question essentially
and we implemented that through this
just-in-time
mentorship study yes yes yeah so it's
funny even mention that because we did
have some we had mentors select who they
went in to help on their own so we had
human mentor self human offices and I'll
go through that in a little bit and it
was actually kind of interesting to see
what mentors thought was available or
was appropriate to feedback to give
novices and at one point they were
slacking them the MCV so you're a
minimum viable example right and there's
a cycle flow patience and how to ask but
the value here or what mentors decide
amongst themselves essentially was if
users already knew those resources if
those new services were helpful they
would already be using them right
so so now this this experience this
mentorship experience now provided or
kind of make concrete the type of
feedback that mentor that knobs is
really need right first is like a long
page of Texas's how to ask exactly again
exactly
so again understand that experience so
this is a good question bin yeah um so
to do this we did this just in time
mentorship study there there were four
design goals and then a lot of them I
won't go over too much but the main
point was that we wanted to understand
the benefits so we can eventually scale
them this experiment does not scale on
this current state we think that really
kill your human mentors and human
offices and I'll talk more about the
recruitment strategies if you're
interested as well but against it's
working collaborating with industry it
was important to understand the question
quality satisfaction of our novices and
our expert users alike and improve that
feedback experience so now go step
through the mentorship study and how
they engage at the platform and then
I'll talk about the data we collected
and I assume to be a lot of questions
about what we had access to and things
like that so step one to enter this
mentorship program our novel to write a
question once they complete the title
and the body of the question there's a
button at the bottom that says you know
post when they press posts a motor will
pop up that says there's the experienced
mentor available to give you feedback on
your question would you like to be would
you like to connect with them or we just
select the post your question and let's
give this an area that the person clicks
yes from there the novices entered
enters a help room this private help
room essentially assisted it's a chat
room stuck Ophuls has chats they had it
for a long time they opened them up to a
larger group of people and a couple
years ago so we just took advantage of
an existing mechanism before they were
for elite users at one point
against their own private no we only
have for help rooms and we had and I'll
talk about that mess couple minutes so
yes yes over 70,000 eloquent offices so
I'll start there and we have for help
rooms thoughts are again again did not
scale we're trying to figure out what we
needed to do so we can scale right so a
good question so the answer the help
room the mentor reached the question and
give us some feedback there present with
automated message at first and then a
human mentor saying you know hi I'm
gonna give you feedback so from there
let's say the mentor continues to
suggest edits for the question anytime
the novice can go in and edit their
questions and this is exactly what it
looks like to use the collaborative
editing feature you still have the same
because it's the markdown text you have
your title your tags etc and you can
actually see the timestamp of when the
last edit was me again mentors can see
this fishing teaching novice is the fish
not fishing for them only novices can
edit questions mentor sketches just
edits in fact at any time throughout
this experience in the novices and find
is helpful they can just disengage and
just say I'm going to post my question
to the platform cool okay so now going
back to the experiment so this was a 33
day study conducted on platform live so
on stackoverflow so we had oh okay yeah
we had for help rooms for help from so
when a novice entered novices were
routed to these help rooms and we had
one private mentor room were amongst
themselves mentors can suggest or select
novices to help and even a muscle cell
even try to figure out what the best
feedback to give a novice that talks
about that FAQ and him CBE as well yeah
so we had 70,000 eligible novices this
is 25 percent of the eligible opposites
we had in this time eligible novice
means any user with less than 15 points
or has asked three questions and
receives an upvote does the this
received up boots because obviously so
the reason we allowed that is for say
for example you asked the question
before but maybe you didn't have a great
experience
it's still viable for use we figured of
super viable system we engage in this
experience so of the 70,000 we have only
about 520 inch at the room which is kind
of expected and we had it was a new
feature and we had kind of expected
these new users to just really be
interested in posting the questions
leaving right that helped me Empire I'm
gonna posted and leave and leave there
we have 271 novices actually engaged we
have a lot of people enter the room and
then just curious peek in and leave both
had 271 novices engaged about 63 mentors
and had 343 conversations and just the
dialogues between each yes good question
so that's also part of the feature not a
bug where where novices can actually see
other people getting feedback so now
it's not like I'm just creepy I'm in
this private room where previously I
know that people on Stack Overflow are
trolls and his trolls is gonna probably
attack me
oh other people are gonna construct a
feedback as well so also we didn't have
enough resources to do like 70,000 rooms
so but we can features so from that
experience we had about we analyzed the
transcripts and we had use of question
scores from each question because an
upvote or downvote and the question kind
of that's how the community perceives
your response or your requested yes Andy
so we had before the study we posted
this post on Stack Overflow meta so meta
stock exchange is the community where
you can experience desert anyone who's
really familiar with it because there's
just new features complain about old
ones so these are so especially this
community of this meta psycho feel
community is re really active in that
feedback process and what's the
improvements or removal of things so
when we posted about the mentorship
program we were doing we're saying we're
doing the study what should it look like
so we arguing feedback on there as well
and at posts we link to a survey where
they can apply to be amador from there
myself and christina less security
researcher at Stack Overflow and the
first researcher at the time we skimmed
the list of us we asked them about their
previous mentorship experiences
so we reviewed their experiences posting
on Stack Overflow
we removed trolls people who were on the
blacklist on Stack Overflow which I
wouldn't had access to if I do this on
my own so that was the the benefit of
working with Chris tackle they had their
own internal list of people who are just
mean I don't know how to say that so
good
so the question we actually surveyed
novices and interviewed mentors I don't
have that in the beat right I might go
about that right now but I can bring
that up if you're interested as well
yes as a proposed reason was that a
consideration this is a good question so
for this experience no and I'll tell you
why again we were trying to target a few
help the many so targeting the few which
is a way for us to understand the
problem for this niche community
essentially but again identifying these
problems this for everyone right um so
these mentors were from all over and
they're all over the globe as well and I
talked a little bit more about similar
from Egypt's and I'm probably talk about
more of them because someone from Egypt
from Assam Russia they were globally
dispersed and that's on purpose because
the novice is answering a question or
asking questions are from all over as
well the offices were only exposed only
presented the option to enter the help
room if a mentor was already in there it
only so that optionally showed up if
there was someone available yes said yes
they're all jobs first
um yes excuse me something also I was
going to answer oh okay sorry
right so for a stock Ophuls logging so
there's no way to verify the gender or
add any other personal stock overflow
and I'll say not yet because I think
there's some pushing towards that so for
logging purposes or we had access to was
when they asked the question and when
they were when they type with the title
of the question and really with the
answer and that and then that point
though that's how we identify that
that's a person there was no other way
to identify that their experiences
before so no pairing mechanisms at this
point but I think a lot of this work
would demonstrate that there's
incentives or there's value in doing a
pairing in that way great question so
Wow high level results we noticed that
mentors questions had higher quality so
what I mean is that we saw a 50%
increase in scorn average from mentor
versus not meant to questions
so in this purpose public I didn't say
that earlier so we conducted this
chi-square analysis on the percentage of
questions using stucco feels very
sophisticated data science framework
which is where positive questions are
marked as good so any question with a
positive score no short questions are
ones with a zero and negative ones are
bad
so essentially so this is this this is
what their day is nice to gave us
because again I mean I'm is own external
at this part we've seen less bad
questions right and more questions so
more positively rated questions so
there are in addition to that we
conducted a qualitative analysis yes so
there are over 500 questions I had when
I looked at it last time so a lot people
did and so there are in our community
triage which is where questions belong
we did see that some mentors actually
just kind of helped navigate questions
that maybe belong to a different
community or didn't even belong as I go
through it all
and I'll talk about that next so so this
is an example of a community OSH where a
mentor went on to say okay the fact is
that misako well you can't ask for all
those libraries you do that somewhere
else so this is an example of one person
on another question saying your question
may belong a superuser or server fault
whether the fact is on Stack Overflow
again there's over a hundred and seventy
two seconds communities Sacco fools one
of them - it's like a stuck exchange
under the sex changer Briella
software engineering is another big one
sometimes be confusing and which
question belong where right but most
novices weren't familiar with that a lot
of people ask me I guess not you know we
talked about the math and the Stack
Exchange or other ones but there's
there's a lot of them there's an area of
50 - you can create and just make your
own second change community but again so
we saw mentors kind of act as our guards
for the community anyway I don't like
cigars but protected community away
where they were able to reroute
questions I didn't belong so one novice
went on to say hey how do i hack a Wi-Fi
password that was it no code snippet
that was that was it and that's an
example of question that this didn't
belong there and it's actually kind of
funny cuz mentors amongst themselves we
had a we had them generate a document
which is art we caught in mentorship FAQ
which is linked in the paper somewhere
but together we decided what is
appropriate before but together much
themselves and myself kind of like
chaired it but what's appropriate to
respond and so we actually kind of see
it was funny to see how they talked
about it and then they went back to
document to kind of you know form have
we're going to perform the dialogue or
how we discourage or reroute questions
so is this the first attempt on
stackoverflow to actually create such
mentors and sort of figure out you know
what we're you know what their behavior
would be like yes um so I think so the
is you so yes this is a garbage
recycling this was the first time doing
it but this is I mentioned christina was
the first researcher so we this this
this is club since 2018 when we did this
in August of 2017 and she had just got
there and it's funny cuz we already had
collapse so there was our dialogues with
other people who were software engineers
who were joining us that overflow and
then when they got the research over
there oh we have a person who can do
this thing from the paper you mentioned
in the blog which is why the blog was
helpful right so yeah yeah yeah it's
funny you even mention that because even
on the meta pages there's so on the meta
stock of overflow page where I said we
propose that we're gonna do this thing
finally people have been proposing so
users have been saying this should be
like some type of coaching guidance but
I think resources
I think resources were a big part of it
yeah right or even how to get buy-in
that this is valuable and and good to do
on the platform which is why I think so
every time we talk about so we're Jeff
and Jeff I was a founder and Julius is
the data scientists they share the blog
right they share the paper because it's
now it's now it's empirical findings and
I'm linking them to other ones as well
and it's like there now that it's a
stated problem external it seems more
viable as opposed I really can't I
really don't know what I've been
[Music]
you know if you have an interaction with
something to be a chat you might your
experience might be improved so that's
one in particular and that's exactly
right so some people um came over his
name Chun yen Chen who submitted papers
to see scw like the following year used
recurrent neural networks to understand
how people are editing posts right so
freaking out how we can automate some of
this Wow do it now yeah right yeah yeah
that is funny one of the other
experiences we had was when the novices
one time they entered the chat and
they're like wait a minute
are you a real person I mean it kind of
speaks to this the the way we talk the
way we help in the help systems in place
to encourage good behavior everything
yeah right but also what isn't
automating nowadays right and again one
of the biggest the categories of buried
was this impersonal interactions right
so not being able to see the human in
someone so that was really interesting
because I mentor was like yes I'm a
human okay let's get back to this got
people to help yes yes
so no so so again psycho foot is not
revealed gender does not qualify our ass
for gender but so then I did a smaller
study so not out of this mentorship
study but yeah okay I was gonna say
something else I'll just talk about it
later
so but we're happening she sent the
survey and she got 4,000 people to
respond and because you know she
actually used automatic translators she
figured out people were in France like
after half a day people were like don't
use Google Translate just tell us in
English we appreciate the effort and
said dear Bob dear Alice and that
increased their chances of taking the
survey factor yeah yeah and just going
back to your point so we didn't ask for
cultures we didn't particularly select
mentors based on their background is
like that as well but we did see that
one novice that women saw after they
helped the novice
they went on to say you know hey are you
from Egypt by chance right and it's
funny because I was in the chat this
time and so was my colleague and we were
like wait a minute are we got the flag
dispersed we weren't sure how this was
gonna go and I'm not just want to say
you know I actually am no thank you for
noticing and they were like okay see you
around right so it'll be interesting to
see if this type of bond kind of
fostered this other type of mentorship
as in our my kind of following that
follow you around but also encourage you
in other questions I'm not gonna check
your behavior and see and bigger cheer
in the corner I always upload you right
so and you can get this type of
information so what I'm saying is that
you can you can actually identify it as
well come on sorrowful you can list your
location even though there's just not
instead leave verified as well as your
name
so this interest but my future we're
just trying to figure out how we get to
give an image of it I'm Alyssa get taken
advantage be actionable about it so
let's skip over this real quick um
helpful thing here with that their games
talk a little bit about automation the
ability to automate some of the findings
so it's kind of we talked about this box
in a way so Sacco feels developer if an
indie group has started this template
this question-asking template
essentially we're okay show your code is
there a code snippet here okay check
right we shouldn't be posting if you're
asking about compiler errors and just
talking about what you did there should
be a code snippet right also your
question sound a lot like this other
question it did you blink to it we can
just mark down we can check for the
brackets in the parentheses okay is
through the link so stack overflow
question you look for the URL right this
ways to automate that kind of makes this
essentially and there in some ways
happening on the Kombi crushed answer
template where you first stop extra
question also go flow but maybe we
should do that elsewhere as well so this
is actually helpful because that's J
Hanlon executive vice president for
develop finding growth no convenien
growth and he highlighted the work as
well and there's summer of change right
so I think it was the ability to have an
academic pairing partner to encourage
this happening and I think that was a
made part of it so after that Julia who
was the data science assess I go flow we
went on to talk about the work with
Christina and myself and started this
academic mentorship or academic research
partnership program so people can
conduct their other studies on platform
and I think it was really I mentioned
this because I think it may be a good
opportunity to encourage organizations
to do that I know Microsoft researchers
are here when it does it obviously but
other organizations as well so even
compare studies across different
platforms with academic partners that
some time about that earlier so so
really cool is gonna happen
alright I'm ready to every so I'll go
over the vision briefly real quick so
I conducted a smaller study on
stackoverflow where we identify
questions where well in the set of B
notice that when women answer questions
from other women they were reengagement
sooner and we call this idea of pure
parity so it's just trying to really
drill deeper to identify if signal of
available identity signals so using this
we use the first name of the user so
it's again not necessarily verified but
being able to see how identity may be
encouraging participation so that in
that brief experiment saw that women
were responding and who answer of course
from other women were responding 330
days sooner cumulative density so to
shine drive home the point that makes it
kind of ask the question when what does
asking for help in the future look like
and I would say that looks a lot like
using identity signals anyway so I think
bogden vessel sq from CMU said it best
software is being globally Oh being
developed by increasingly distributed
and increasingly diverse groups of
individuals I would say that how our
programmers identities presented it will
become recently influential so to kind
of drive from that point I'll briefly
talk about three projects that I could
see myself conducting here at Microsoft
and they sent it around contest collapse
control over presentation of identity
and empowerment so for the first one we
should consider spam emails
so these footers are helpful for weeding
out emails that may not be as helpful or
that you don't need so it's for example
using signals of trust such as have I
received the email first person before
at this person set malicious content to
others as well I would say that software
engineers are using similar signals to
trust signals or to trust pull requests
from each other
but are they using the right signals
what are the right signals do these
signals change based on attributes of
the code so your entire looking at a
brief image a video that connected this
work is focused at X he sees this over
sending it in May that before I run it
back but before the person can make a
verbal contribution or verbally
acknowledged whether or not they going
to accept or so merge or not merciful
requests they go on to look at the
profile before so this is the code
snippet that one commits of your pull
request that's me and my bun it was a
high bun that day and then here you look
at the before they make a decision
they're going back to the profile image
they're going back to their contribution
activity to make before they make a
decision before the Arab League notch
is this the way that developers always
want to be reflected or is this really
reflective contributions should we build
system to give developers more control
over how they share contributions based
on the pull request they're submitting
so maybe we should be able to reduce and
amplify signals based on based on the
type of submit pull requests were
submitting a mission and see what that
looks like
also as online communities begin to
evolve we're starting to see a lot more
control of variety of who you can share
with and and how so this ability to ask
questions to a specialized audience does
that does that allow the depth of
technical knowledge that were able to
this should be increased also this is a
little ability to have the segmented
anonymity of how we communicate this
knowledge does that encourage computing
be more pervasive and when I when I say
that I want us to think about as our
online communities as I traditionally
technical communities become more social
so github now having statuses as of a
couple months ago and are traditionally
social communities become more technical
it's just an example of someone asking
for SDKs on Facebook on my Facebook feed
at least this is a lot again does this
allow me to be more pervasive does this
this context collapse of these
communities this is allow us more to
bring our authentic self from our
offline spaces into our technical
contributions so again going back to the
evaluation should I be evaluated on
those as well if they're going to be
available I'm interested in the study
how that kind of collapse shifts or how
that contest collapse allows social
capital shift in these communities and
how we communicate our technical
knowledge
I'm going over this kind of fast class
when I'm way over time at this point and
finally in our previous my previous
study I did on I look at whoa whoa whoa
I look like an engineer on Twitter and
we were able to see that when
identifiable marginalized identities
we're able to connect they were able to
have the shared being the only one Ness
essentially and be able to feel more
empowered in these spaces and there's
encouraged to engage in their specific
engineering disciplines is there a ways
to kind of recreate this for software
developers specifically in these
communities that were engaging in
because if you think about it if these
marginalized people are not engaging in
our deep technical communities where are
they seeking help where are they going
why aren't we there how do we make our
spaces looking like those even even
better right
so referring to communities like ask
questions that check which brands itself
has this inclusive place to ask
technical questions so they're using a
discourse platform as well as our studio
as well as they are starting to
emphasize more than the ability to be
civil and encourage healthy
conversations but maybe this ability to
have cultural identity be prevalent or V
visible salient is valuable excuse me so
Phillip well in this Python tutor tool
if you log on to Python tutoring select
get life hope you'll be able to see that
other users from different countries or
yeah from different countries it's
winter so in the u.s. OS countries as
well Spain in Ohio if you're able to
connect people based on their cultural
demographic so where they're located
does that encourage people to engage in
a different way
but even more so how can we kind of
encourage people to use these tools so
thinking about from the sack overflow
developer survey Visual Studio was the
most highly responded to of the most
popular tool the developer said they use
34% it was about 70,000 over 70,000
developers and against is at the global
scale these tools allow other people to
contribute right through through
extensions I mentioned extensions
earlier is there a way to kind of
encourage participation through yeah do
building inclusive extensions in the way
though what does that even mean right
when is inclusive extensions look like I
know a lot of a lot of times the
sometimes effort is placed on the
marginalized people to build these
systems we as researchers we as allies
have the ability to lead the dialog and
how these systems can be built Visual
Studio is perfect out of the box tool
you can add extensions to an engage can
be sick should be encouraged the ability
to build extensions around these
cultural competencies this one is about
gender language if you can see it's kind
of hard to see some winner actually says
[Music]
the question so my philosophy is that is
yes and there's values in having things
not be identifiable if that's how you as
the user chooses to be visible any
spaces so I believe I find it valuable
to have the marginalized communities be
able to communicate and have signals of
identity if they so choose
could the values being able to connect
the game go back to and much earlier
connect with other shared marginalized
identities there's value added there but
maybe you want to connect with other
people as well you should be able to
have the ability to decide whether you
want to be presenting to one community
differently than the other that's what
I'm emphasizing that's that's that's
what I'm trying to say so for example if
I identify
as a woman very visibly women right
identifies a woman maybe I want to be
very visible to other women so maybe
there's a badge I want to be able to
have on my account the only other women
can see so they know for sure like okay
I see her and maybe there's certain
opportunities or ascendant contexts --is
of when I'm submitting or making it
something a new extension but I don't
want all that information available
unless I've already engage with that
person in a different context right so
good question yeah so the way I kind of
I think I had a nice little way I was
going to say this oh ok repeat what I
said here can we intentionally craft
opportunities to invite diverse
perspectives to the table be equitable
with the resources the bill so
encouraging people to build these
extensions and then inclusively sustain
participation and that looks different
for everyone
everyone needs different resources to be
supportive so it's a lot of YouTube
tutorials to learn how to do extensions
on visit your studio maybe this is our
way to kind of encourage cultural like
encourage cultural competencies here and
build these fun build fun extensions
that search for how you can remove
gender context from your from your code
or remove profanity if that's something
you're interested in that's the other
picture I had removed but um but yeah so
I'm interested in studying that and what
that looks like it's very open but I
think there's there's something
interesting there so in summary I talked
a little bit about the unfamiliar norms
and how those can present barriers to
underrepresented groups including women
and novices in these platforms in these
programming communities but
understanding these barriers as a
framework can be helpful to build
interventions such as just-in-time
mentorship experience that kind of
reduces to two million community size
this fear and negative feedback we
flipped a bit on that to have
constructive feedback in a private space
and I propose that this vision of we can
learn how to empower connect and build
systems are kind of take advantage of
identity signals they're already there
people are using them how do we get
smart about using them how do we get
smart about giving control to other
people or how they'd want to be used
so with that I'll close and I'll thank
you all for your time so it seems like
one opportunity you know instead of sort
of thinking about safe Stack Overflow
and its history and things like that is
to think about you know there's many
more people will be entering this kind
of world and the education it's a space
around how people are being educated you
know or about computers man so do you
have thoughts about how you know if you
sort of you start with a blank slate you
know and you can you know you could
you're creating let's say we're gonna
have 10 times as many programmers 10
years from now as we have right now like
there's you know nine-tenths of those
people are new could we could create
leverage that yeah um I I agree there
was this number buying either Evans data
or a yearís Bureau of Labor Statistics
that said by 2023 she's actually coming
up now we will need 43 million
developers 40 million developers at this
rate will have 23 million by that time
so this is this idea of the technical
jobs that are starting to arise so that
including data scientists software
engineers diffent people working on
information retrieval right so there is
a need is a gaps to fill um I think that
from the edge case perspective I think
these online tools the people are have
are valuable and it's kind of sometimes
kind of disturbing to find out that I'll
use only tools like on Stack Overflow
there's no verify verification of your
identity you could be anyone you want to
be right and and that's still
discouraging so I think figuring out how
we can make it more comfortable to be
you can be whoever you want to be make
that more salient more clear that that's
okay can allow us to understand across
even other cultures because it's
different every country and every
different culture has different norms
how we'll make it more comfortable or
maybe more accepting for you to bring
that to these platforms to bring that to
your coding experiences why should you
have to check that at the door right
it's a good question Ben yeah I'm sort
of curious on the flipside has anybody
ever done a study of the jerks so my
people who are on the blacklist
yeah because right now we're treating
them as a black box so to speak of life
we have newcomers who are contributing
and then the black box is coming and
squashing them right but could we open
up the black box and figure out because
I can imagine a variety of motivations
for the jerky behavior and some of them
are probably you know you could have
interventions for those as well
I don't know we're just curious since
you know the literature has anybody
studied the bad behavior so first are
just the earlier part essentially the
people who are mentors could have been
exhibiting jerky behavior they're
moderators right and the moderators
would close your question and mark your
questions protected in to say prevent
spam right and I think giving them
giving space making a space where we're
declaring it as this helpful
constructive thing which is essentially
overdoing with the private mentorship
example we had some people who were just
who actually were saying like
inappropriate hateful things so there's
those people blacklist
but the essentially the moderators could
have been perceived it's just that and I
think exactly giving them that space to
say this is constructive keep the user
in mind I think the example that Jeff
Atwood had before of this is a new is a
novice user like and there's a hand wave
like be kind or think about the code of
contact before you engage
I think being explicit about that it was
valuable so even on github there's this
contributor covenant that uh Febrary
Keeney who was uncharted their community
and growth they came up with this
covenant so that every project could
adopt it if they chose to affair of how
to engage with new users what was their
appropriate moderation techniques and I
think so that's an example of people
trying to develop that and use it on
their own but I think Stack Overflow
density of Stack Overflow being the the
leader saying declaring it that this is
a safe space was a different tone versus
if I'm just the one who just logged in
right now and said you can't talk to me
like that you shouldn't talk to people
like that
so I think it's important for the people
in power the communities and power and
the leadership in power to be able to on
their aside feel assistance and make it
explicit that it's okay yeah
so I questioned about the novices and
the questions that they asked so one of
the things that you see on Stack
Overflow in terms of sort of obnoxious
responses maybe not yeah and part of
that is because people I mean a bottom
novices put on questions that are either
searches right it's really there they
ask a question like I have a bug why
doesn't this work and there's no
information or the worst is like
homework yeah yeah yeah and so I
wondered of the novices and the
questions that they asked in your study
yeah yeah so I can tell you that at the
end of the 33 days so this is probably
questions that were latter in more in
the beginning 15% work hello most 18%
were deleted and that was in and then I
mentioned all less bad more good they
were still alive
this doesn't mean there was a lot of
negative negative questions right and
they and they be sample homework
questions and they've written offices
and mentors were giving the feedback of
like again your the question the reason
I said there's able to automate that
process there was a lot of that where
mentors were like I could just answer
this question for them or like that's
not what this context is for you you
know but so but the mentor would suggest
this sounds a lot like this can't have
you checked it and I think that having
that automate is important I was gonna
say something else too I came to the
other end of your question but
all right it's all tea leaves today
that's perceived as jerky is because of
gatekeeping in a different way than the
way back oh yes yes yes okay so also and
I think I kind of try to lose this
earlier with this transactional
mentality some people how they use a
chlorophyll where they perceiving it as
I'm just going to ask somebody for a
quick and like I'm tacking you and I'm
like I want you to give me this answer
and that's how some people asking
homework questions we would use the
platform and it's the transaction that's
the forum part of it and I think the
issue here is there's a contrast of
mental models of how those people think
the community should work versus how the
expert users were talking about before
see it as this wiki right at this
archive is artifact that shouldn't be
kept up then moderated delicately
writing in preserved and I think that's
the value of the mentorship program is
because it kind of offered this non
archival in a way it's still archived
that you still go search for it but you
now have that ability to have that quick
transaction because it is it's a chat
right so maybe there should be always as
rite of passage where novices should be
to learn the norms in this platform
first before engaging on the artifact
but but if you think about it the reason
some questions are like artifact is
because wool job has been around since
forever we're new link we just pop up
like go and check it right there's a new
opportunity to determine how we're going
to talk about a language and maybe it's
more important to have that quick banter
right you know so so I think it would
depend based on language yeah this is a
good question but
yeah cool even on yeah cuz I'm so stuck
like metaphor of a psycho fool had it
for a while but it was a little B's and
I knew about is cuz I'm a previous study
one of my participants the expert
usually was saying yeah we have this
chat thing we've been using for a minute
and then they opened it up so you and in
order to use a chat you have to have 15
hit those 20 points to engage in the
chat you can look at it if you know the
chat gonna go through but you cannot
engage so it's kind of also saying
novice I shouldn't go here I kind of
think that should be kind of shifted if
we put them there first before we
preserve archive right so um so yeah yes
where do you see accessibility
your research agenda doesn't fit because
I see that as another creating oh one
hundred percent
hundred percent so I was thinking
exactly of that when Andy was talking
about I know he works with the
neuro-diverse right so thinking about
how the platform's of ability to
building extensions what I'm trying to
get at so when you're building
extensions and thinking about the value
they add two different groups of people
and that's a perfect opportunity to do
that so you can't lead to the image but
again that one was for that one was for
removing gendered language or I think it
also said something but country religion
race related gender favoring unequal
phrasing right so that that was very
like a son brother thing if we're gonna
build this tool to help you remove these
this types of output coming out when
you're debugging your code
I think there's opportunities to build
tools for how we're working on
extensions or build extensions that kind
of enhance half the capabilities so
thinking about so for people who have
visual impairments being able to have
haptic feedback versus and so no visual
feedback no audio feedback but anyways
to build and haptic feedback into this
extension so that you can further I'm
gonna say engage with the platform a
different way and have it personalized
to your experience so bespoke to your
experience yeah but but I would
encourage but we need developers to be
encouraged to build extensions that do
that and we shouldn't be relying on the
mega marginalized community to build
those systems so we should be
encouraging encouraging type of
development and I think that's what's
missing yeah yeah just thinking out loud
of supposed to be operationalized to say
like the tone of the way
because especially what this one does
that one does so if you can't read a
small font perhaps trying to like be
funny a little bit so I spent some time
last night trying to identify other
cultural ways of engaging so I was
searching things like race gender
religion and try stalking Egypt because
that was the example I gave earlier
there's not many that kind of high like
that and that extensions that are
exposing available here on this tool
yeah yeah I mean I thought this one
normally happens yeah yes science small
number of contributors who do like the
lion share actual work and things like
that so I was just curious I guess had
two questions the first was that like
how generalizable in general do you
think some of the things you found in
dishes and stack overflow which is kind
of wouldn't be useful in general for
other citizen science initiatives other
online communities overall and then the
second one is that for your novices I
really like to Brendan like the
questions the asking questions I was
wondering - if there's like some room
there until I bring novices in on the
more question answering side because it
seems to be like you have there could be
novices in two different ways you could
have novice as interns like I'm new to
programming so I'm just I'm learning
familiar things with programming syntax
and things like that and I'm going to
stack overflow some anonymous in both
ways people in this room lurkers so
right excuse that overflow than
everything you'd ever just gone in and
act like answered a question and if you
want to build up this like richer more
diverse more inclusive community it
seems like you have to like attack it
from both sides like if you're bringing
in more people ask questions but the
people are asking questions they're
still the same group of people from the
same thing it seems like you'd be like
running into issues there so then you
also have dots too about how to bring in
more people to scaffold the
question/answer inside as well yes a
hundred so yes and mortis so for the for
the answering side the way we try to get
at the fact that with us like to answer
or what how that encourages people is
that that briefing pre parity study I
mentioned but going back just going
diving deeper to what you meant to the
second time is there's more
opportunities to answer questions
there's not answers getting close
because they're duplicates right that
people aren't doing that they're just
we're most likely being downloaded for
not valuable and I think there's a big
opportunity to encourage that so that's
the core o explanation that's actually
as a different type of utility and value
to stock overflow because some people
same whether you stock go for the way to
use kora which is they have multiple
answers that are there and and that's it
and that's the benefit of using it being
able to have multiple perspectives to
the same answer to the same question
so yes and then first part you mentioned
it built the tea house he house
to like do more editing on Wikipedia's
got a lot of work on like dinking knows
onboarding processes so i'm just
wondering like the generalizability in
general like these online forms citizen
science communities or things that
you're learning here that could just be
like generalizable come a design guide
by citizen science platform they should
think about yes
yes so I think that what so yes it does
transfer exactly so I think the only
thing is unique here is that we're
talking about that the technical
contribution here is code there's other
technical contributions in other forms
right if I'm doing math deck is saying
I'm talking about theories right and
that's the technical contribution and
that's format a different way as well
what's super generalizable is the belief
to have a pathway to participation which
is what legitimate peripheral
participation is a way to introduce
low-hanging fruits to to give your
novices or your newcomers to the
platform to encourage them to as a way
to get them practiced and warmed up
before they contribute and I think being
able to have a chat so rewriting people
to the chat first if they never if they
never answered a question before gives
them the opportunity so the low-hanging
fruit of we used to build points up by
engaging in the chat and then you're
building up how to encourage or how to
talk about technical topics if you're on
this platform and then transferring them
to other communities and that's what the
tea house kind of what from what I
understood at the tea house that was
what they were trying to do and that's
the only difference it looks different
based on the what's the main interaction
in different communities as well because
this one is mostly Q&A in that forum /
wiki but on places like Wikipedia is
really just straight straight wiki it's
kind of like more of debating of what's
appropriate with the appropriate archive
to hold for our topic so I think so yes
I'm gonna use question sir okay
good question questions anyone thank you
thank you